[Musique]
la vie a tendance à nous tester et quand
tu fait le mauvais choix
vivre avec ce que tu as fait peut-être
ton propre châtiment une routarde
sorbonne zola
[Musique]
je viens d'être libéré d'une prison
fédérale et j'essaie de me remettre sur
pied maintenant voilà ma vie prenez un
moment pour examiner l'arc pas le droit
de tenir une arme n'est ce pas
le clou
viens tient voyez vous ça
ça c'est ma gentil fille
[Musique]
ne vous focalisez pas sur ce qui n'est
pas réparable focalisez vous sur ce
qu'il est qu'est ce que tu veux vraiment
de la crème glacée et la justice
[Musique]
ah ah
je n'avais jamais entendu rire avant
cette terrifiante que faire quand on
atteint le moment on sait plus quoi
faire
on va traverser tous ces ensembles donc
ça sera comme au bon vieux temps
abandonnée n'est pas la réponse c'est
bon de voir
[Musique]
nous devons trouver nos propres réponses
tu devrais pas avoir peur c'est la
première étape pour avancer
je les luttes dans une brochure
ça pourrait être le début d'un nouveau
départ
on puisse repartir d'un bon pied ok
c'est parti
regardez
maintenant c'est une pour les
différentes
c'est une poule magique est dit pas la
faune
[Musique]